عمده كييف يعلن التصدي لهجمات جويه على
العاصمه في ماموسكو تؤكد احباطها جميع
محاولات التقدم الاوكراني في دنيا
الناخبون في الكويت يتوجهون بعد نحو ساعه
لصناديق الاقتراع الاختياري 50 نائبا في
مجلس الامه
بعد غيابه عن جلسه الامس الاميره هاري
يدلي بشهادته اليوم امام المحكمه في لندن
في سابقه تاريخيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر في اخر
تطورات الحرب قالت القياده العسكريه في
جنوب اوكرانيا ان القوات الروسيه فجرت سد
نضاك خوفكا في منطقه خرسون وهو الامر الذي
نفاه عمده المدينه كما اكدت الاداره
العسكريه ان نظم الدفاع الجوي تدخلت لصد
غارات جويه على منطقه كييف في ساعه مبكره
من صباح الثلاثاء فيما اشار عمده كييف الى
ان ذوي الانفجارات في كيف كان نتيجه تدخل
نظام الدفاع الجوي بصد الهجمات الروسيه من
جهتها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
احبطت هجوما اوكرانيا كبيرا جدا في منطقه
والحقت بقوتك
مع استمرار القوات الاوكرانيه في القتال
اوكرانيا تعلن احراز نجاحات قرب بخموت
وروسيا تؤكد صد هجوم كبير الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودوميرزالينسكي اشاد
بالمكاسب التي حققتها قواته قرب مدينه
بخموت وسخر في الوقت ذاته من رد فعل روسيا
الذي وصفه بالهستي
راينا الرد الروسي الهستيري على مكاسبنا
في قطاع بخموت وموسكو تدرك ان اوكرانيا
ستنتصر
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت انها
احبطت هجوما اوكرانيا على خمسه قطاعات من
الجبهه في اتجاه جنوب دوناتسك وانها كبدت
اكياز خسائر فادحه
بالمقابل نفت هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه بدء الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد الموعود
مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
غرد ساخرا ان روسيا منشغله بالفعل بشكل
نشط في صد هجوم شامل لم يحصل بعد من جهتها
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه هنمليار
اعلنت ان القوات الاوكرانيه تنفذ عمليات
هجوميه في بعض القطاعات وهو ما اكده رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
الذي اشار الى خساره جزء من بلده برخيفكا
في قطاع مخموت
خبراء وجنود روس توقعوا ان تصاعد القوات
الاوكرانيه هجماتها لجس النبض قبل اطلاق
الهجوم الكبير
بينما اكد وزير الخارجيه
ان مخططات الغرب المناهضه لروسيا محكوم
عليها بالفشل وان الشعب الروسي لا يشك
بهذه الحقيقه قيدء
تنطلق خلال ساعات الانتخابات التشريع
الكويتيه لاختيار اعضاء مجلس الامه
2023 الذين يصل عددهم الى 50 نائبا من اصل
207 مرشحين بينهم ثلاثه عشره امراه وستفتح
مراكز الاختراع البالغ عددها
118 مركزا ابوابها عند الساعه الثامنه
صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي للخامسه بتوقيت
جرينتش بعد نحو ساعه من الان ولمده 12
ساعه
لتبدا عمليه فرز الاصوات بعد انتهاء
الانتخابات مباشره للاعلان عن نواب الذين
سيمثلون الكويتيين لمده اربع سنوات مقبله
السادس من يونيو هو اليوم الذي تترقبه
الكويت من اجل اختيار 50 نائبا يمثلها تحت
قبه عبد الله سالم يترشح للسباق انتخابات
مجلس الامه 2003
مرشحين ومرشحه
وزاره العدل خصصت
759 لجنه انتخابيه بعدما جهزت وزاره
التربيه
وثمانيه عشره مدرسه وحولتها لمركز اقتران
يتوجه اليها نحو
794 الف ناخب وناخبه لاختيار نائب واحد في
دائرتهم المسجلين فيها
الكويت هو مصلحه شعبها فوق اي اعتبار هذا
ابرز الشعارات المرشحين الذين حاولوا
التقرب من الناخبين بشعاراتهم وندواتهم
الانتخابيه التي ناقش فيها مطالب الشعب
واسباب تاخر تحقيقها في المجالس السابقه
الا ان الترقب الاكبر يبقى على استمراريه
المجلس وعمل السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه مع بعضهما من الكويت شاهد
المتروك العربيه
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان عددا من جنوده
سيشاركون للمره الاولى بصوره فعاله في
اضخم تدريبات عسكريه في القاره السراء
وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي في بين ان وفدا من
12 جنديا وقائدا من كتيبه جولان
الاستطلاعيه غادروا الى المغرب للمشاركه
في مناورات الاسد الافريقي
2023 التي تنطلق اليوم وتستمر حتى السادس
عشر من الشهر الجاري يذكر ان مناورات
الاسد الافريقيه التي ينظمها سنويا المغرب
والولايات المتحده بصوره مشتركه
ستجرى بنسختها التاسع عشره وسيشارك فيها
نحو 8000 عسكري من ثمانيه عشره دوله
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه جنديين في
حادث دهس بسياره قربه بلده حواره في الضفه
الغربيه وقال الجيش في بيان ان احد
الجنديين اصيب بجروح متوسطه فيما تعرض
الاخر لاصابات طفيفه وكانت التلفزيون
الاسرائيلي نقل في وقت سابق عن الجيش قوله
ان التقييم الاولي اشار الى ان الواقعه
كانت حادثا عربيا وليس هجوما
[موسيقى]
قدم مايك بينس نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب رسميا اوراق الترشحه
لخوض الانتخابات التمهيديه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري تمهيدا لخوض سباق الرئاسه
الامريكيه عامه
في وقت سابق نيته الترشح عن الحزب
الجمهوري ليكون منافسا لرئيسه السابق تمر
ومن المنتظر بحسب وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
ان ينشر مايك بينس تفاصيل حملته خلال
اليومين القادمين
يبدو الباب مفتوحا امام الجمهوريين لاطلاق
حملاتهم الانتخابيه والطموح الى ترشيح
الحزب لاحدهم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وقد
تجمعوا في ولايه ايوا للتحدث الى الناخبين
بضيافه السيناتور الجمهوريه جوني ايرلز
سنسمع من مرشحين رئاسيين مميزين جدا
الغائب
وهو يتقدم على جميع المرشحين ويحظى بتاييد
50% من الجمهوريين فيما يحظى حاكم فلوريدا
بمعدل 20% والاخرون لا يتعدى تاييد كل
واحد منهم الخمسه
هناك فرصه للتغيير وراي الناس سيتغير فتره
الان يحظى بشعبيه مبنيه على ولايته الاولى
في البيت الابيض
عمل اغلب المرشحين في ظل رئاسه او تحالف
معه لكنهم يطرحون انفسهم الان بدائل عنهم
وتجتهد المرشحه في القول انه يجب البحث عن
قياده جديده ما كان يجب ان يحصل اي من هذا
توفرت سنه كامله لبيدنج يمنع الحرب في
اوكرانيا ولم يفعل شيئا
فيما يدخل مايكل السباق وهو يتهم دولار
ترامب بتعريض سلامته للخطر لدى اجتياح
مبنى الكونجرس في السادس من يناير 2021
فرامل
علاقتنا لم تنتهي على خير وافترقنا بصداقه
اما الان فانظر الى المستقبل واقول ان
لدينا خيارات افضل
من الصدف الجيده ان بيتر رعف يعرف جيدا
قبل
منذ زمن طويل وقبل ان يكون نائبا في
الكونجرس مؤمن باسس ايمانه الغفران والكبر
مهمان جدا لديه ولا اعتقد انه يترشح لانه
يريد عرقله دونالد ترامب حاكم نيوجيرسي
السابق كريستي انسحب لصالح ترامب في العام
2016 لكن ترامب تخلى عن خدماته خلال
المرحله الانتقاليه
ويحتفظ كريستي بغضب ضد الرئيس السابق منذ
ذلك الحين مره جديده تبدو الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه وكانها بشان ترامب فهو
يحتفظ باعلى شعبيه لدى الجمهوريه
والمرشحون الجدد يراهنون على تراجع هذه
الشعبيه مع بدء الانتخابات التمهيديه في
الغنم العربيه واشنطن
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعنا فيها بعد الفاصل
تعزيزات او تعزيزات النيتو تبدا في الوصول
الى كوسوفو لمواجهه اعمال عنف ادت لاصابه
30 جنديه من قواته حلف شمال الاطلسي
اهلا بكم من جديد نشير مشاهدينا الى الخبر
العاجل الذي تتابعونه على الشاشه حيث اكد
مسؤول موالي لروسيا بانه لا خطوره على
محطه زبروج النوويه حتى الان بعد تفجير سد
نوفا كخوفكا اوكرانيا كانت اكدت ان القوات
الروسيه فجرت هذا السد في خرسون
اعلنت المتحدثه باسم حلف في شمال الاطلسي
اونلاينج اسكو عبر صفحتها الرسميه على
موقع تويتر اكدت ان تعزيزات الناتو بدات
في الوصول الى كوسوفو في اعقاب اعمال
العنف التي وقعت الاسبوع الماضي والذي
اسفلت عن اصابه 30 جنديا من قوات النيتو
لحفظ السلام في كوسوفو واضافت المتحدثه
بان الجزء الاكبر من التعزيزات يتكون من
نحو 500 جندي من كتيبه المظاليين التركيه
التابعه للواء مشاه الميكانيكي رقم خمسه
وستين
اكد رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه تراجع نسبه
عبور المهاجرين عبر القوارب غير الشرعيه
بنسبه 20% مقارنه بالوقت ذاته من العام
الماضي مشيرا الى ان خطته لوقت القوارب
بدات تقطف ثمارها وكشف سونات عن جهوزيه
سفينتين لايواء مئات المهاجرين من مراكز
الايواء والفنادق
في مهمه للايفاء بوعده في خفض قوارب
الهجره غير النظاميه متجاهلا احدث نتائج
استطلاع للراي وجد ان سته اشخاص من بين كل
عشره بريطانيين يعتقدون ان سوناك بصدد
الفشل في تحقيق وعوده لكن السوناك يرى
خلاف ذلك معددا خلال خطاب القاه من الجانب
الانجليزي لقناه عبور المهاجرين مؤشرات
نجاح خطته في وقف القوارب معلنا عن تراجع
نسبه عبور المهاجرين بعشرين في المائه
ما زال امامنا طريق طويل لكن منذ اطلاق
الخطه في الاشهر الخمسه الماضيه انخفضت
نسبه العبور بعشرين في المئه مقارنه
بالعام الماضي
بالاضافه الى جهوزيه سفينتين لاواء نحو
الف مهاجر غير قانوني وترحيل 1800 الباني
الى بلادهم ضمن اتفاق ابرمته الحكومه مع
البانيا
لقد اعدنا الان 1800 مهاجر الى البانيا في
غضون سته اشهر فقط
خطه السوناك وحكومه تواجه انتقادات عده في
مجلس اللوردات الذي يرى ان الخطه لا تلتفت
في جوهرها الى اخلاقيات التعامل مع
المهاجرين حجه ترى حكومه السوناك انها
كلام فقط ولا تقدم حلولا عمليه للتعامل او
احتواء ازمه المهاجرين
عقبات اخلاقيه وقانونيه يواجهها مشروع
قانون الهجره من سياسيين وطالبي لجوء
وحقوقيين وصفو سياسات الحكومه بالقاسيه
ولا تاخذ بالاعتبار اللاجئين
جزء كبير من مشروع قانون الهجره هو ببساطه
غير عملي والحكومه عمليا لن تكون قادره
على ازاله اعداد كبيره من الاشخاص لكن
السوناك افترض ان الهاربين من الموت او
التعذيب كما تزعم الروايات الالاف من
المهاجرين يعني انهم لن يمانعوا سياسات
ستبقيهم في امان على الاقل بحسب اعتباراته
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
قبل الامير البريطاني هاري عن جلسه بمقر
المحكمه العليا في لندن تنظر في دعوى
رفعها ضد مؤسسه صحفيه بريطانيه ما دفع
القاضي الى القول بانه مندهش لغيابه في
حين اعتبر احد محاميه المؤسس الصحفيه ان
غيابه غير عاديه ومن المتوقع ان يدلي
الامر هاري بشهادته على منصه الشهود اليوم
ليصبح اول فرد رفيع المستوى في الاسره
المالكه البريطانيه يدلي بشهادته امام
محكمه منذ 130 عاما
عشرات القنوات المحليه والدوليه امام
المحكمه العليا في لندن تتابع مقاضاه
الامير هاري وشخصيات مشهوره لصحيفه ميرو
لنشرها معلومات عنهم بشكل غير قانوني
لكن بعد كل الانتظار لم ترصد الكاميرات
وصول الامير هاري لغيابه عن الجلسه
الافتتاحيه في المحكمه لاسباب تتعلق بعرض
بيانات وادله تتطلب يوما كاملا بحسب
محاميه وهو ما اعتبره فريق الدفاع صحيفه
ميرور مضيعه للوقت خصوصا وانه يريد
التدقيق في ادله المرافعه باستجواب الامير
هاري كشاهد لدحض ادعاءاته بان نشر
معلوماته كانت بطرق غير شرعيه
سواء ربح او خسر القضيه فهو يريد احراج
وسائل الاعلام وبعض افراد العائله المالكه
من خلال هذه المحاكمه فهذه بالنسبه له
حمله يصر على قيادتها فيما يعتقد الاخرون
انه هوس مرضي
الامير هذه اختار المواجهه والادلاء
بافادته كاول شاهد لفرد من العائله
الملكيه منذ اكثر من قرن من الزمن يحمل
الصحف الشعبيه مسؤوليه مقتل والده ديانا
واضطراب علاقته بالعائله الملكه التي ذبت
على التجنب المحاكم لمنع الادلاء بشهادتها
بشان امور قد تكون محرجه يوم تاريخي في
القضاء البريطاني عندما يدلي الامير هاري
بشهادته في المحكمه وقد يكشف المزيد من
اسرار العائله المالكه ليعمق خلافته معها
ومخالفه التقليد بمقابضات الصحيفه على ما
يزعم ضد رغبات والدي الملك تشارلز الذي
يقضي اجازه خاصه في رومانيا لندن
قالت صحيفه ان العالم يشهد انهيارا في
معدلات الخصوبه لدرجه انه مع نهايه هذا
القرن سيشهد كوكب الارض تراجعا في عدد
السكان لاول مره منذ انتشار الطعون الاسود
في اوروبا في القرن الرابع عشر
بشريا فاليابانيون لا ينجبون
يتراجع في اليابان عدد السكان للعام
الثاني عشر على التوالي الحكومه وضعت خطه
لصرف 25 مليار دولار سنويا لتشجيع الانجاب
بعد تراجع معدل الخصوبه الى واحد فاصله
اثنين بالعشره
اعتقد ان الحكومه يجب ان تقلل من ضغط
تربيه الاطفال وان تقدم لنا المزيد من
الدعم يجب ان يستثمروا اكثر في موارد
التعليم في الوقت الحاضر لا يرغب الكثير
من الناس في انجاب الاطفال اذا لم يكن
لديهم الموارد لتوفير تعليم جيدا لهم
اذا بقي الامر على حاله سينخفض عدد سكان
اليابان خلال الاربعين سنه القادمه من 125
مليون الى 87 مليون نسمه والامر لا ينحصر
فقط في اليابان
صحيفه ايكونوميس تحذر من عواقب اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه وخيمه سكان الكوكب سيتراجعون مع
نهايه القرن وذلك للمره الاولى منذ تفشي
الطاعون الاسود في القرن الرابع عشر
العديد من البلدان مثل الصين واليابان
وسنغافوره وتايوان كانوا يحاولون اشياء
مختلفه لتحقيق معدل نمو اعلى في عدد
السكان كان هذا من خلال الحوافز الماليه
لانجاب الاطفال لكن هذه الامور لم تكن
فعاله مثل ما رايناه في بعض البلدان
الاخرى مثل المانيا وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
في العالم منها الصين والهند والولايات
المتحده عدد من يموتون سنويا يتجاوز عدد
من يولدون
تراجعت معدلات الخصوبه مع بدايه الالفيه
الجديده من 2.7 الى اثنين فاصله ثلاثه
واذا وصلت الى اثنين في العشره اي كل
زوجين ينجبان طفلين فقط فهذا يعني ان
البشر سيبداون في التناقص
[موسيقى]
تعيش اهالي الاهوار الجنوبيه في العراق
ازمه جفاف غير مسبوقه ادت الى نفوق
الاسماك وتسببت كذلك بموجات هجره للسكان
سدود تركيه ايرانيه بنيت قبل سنوات على
هذه المياه تقاسم الجيران الخيرات ودفع
صاحبها الثمن على شاطئ الاهوار الجنوبي
بالعراق يقف الصيادون يتاملون زوارقهم
المهجوره من جهه وعذوبه المياه من جهه
اخرى لربما يكون الرزق وفيرا يجرفون صيدا
قاتما سمكات صغيره تصلح فقط لعلف
الحيوانات
يستذكرون اياما كانت هذه الارض تفيض
بالمياه العذبه على امتداد النظر
اولا السدود سادين علينا الماي وثانيا
الماء هو نفسي تجاف ماكو ما يقوي واحنا
ناس معانين حلالنا موت قتل الجوع
اكتفاء ذاتي ووفره في المياه هكذا كان
الحال في الاهوار قبل سنوات حروب وازمات
سياسيه عصفت بالمنطقه فتبدل الحال وصار
السكان هم الخاسر الاكبر وتحول النزوح
بحثا عن مهنه جديده الخيار الاول اعلام
الصياعيد هي اللي تركت وظائف ماكو عمل ما
كان بالنسبه لي لا احصل وظيفه بالنسبه
يعني تفيدني اقدر اسدهن بالنسبه لسؤال
العمل ما يسد يعني
هذه المنطقه كانت محميه طبيعيه ضمن لائحه
التراث العالمي قبل ست سنوات لكن حاله
الجفاف القائم مدفوع بعاصفه كامله من
العوامل المسببه يقول الخبراء ورغم اعلان
الحكومه عن خطط للحد من الجفاف الا ان
تحذيرات كبيره يطلقها المختصون بكارثه
بيئيه قريبه هذه المناطق احيائها بالماء
العذب وهذا شيء ثابت وايضا احيائها بان
تكون محميه على الدوله ان تلتفت بشكل
واقعي والدوله ايضا انا اعتقد انه الدوله
هي مشوار الا بالخارطه
موجات نزوح كبيره يعيشها الاف العراقيين
بحثا عن ارض وفره بالمياه والرزق بعدما
تحولت مستنقعات الاهوار الى بنيه قائمه
مليئه بالزوارق الخشبيه المهجوره والاسماك
الميته
تهدد الانهيارات الصخريه في تعز حياه
العشرات من المواطنين خاصه القاطنين تحت
المرتفعات الجبليه نتابع
حياه هؤلاء لا تهددها الحرب حسب بل
الانهيارات الصخريه المتساقطه على رؤوسهم
هذه الطفله احدى ضحايا انهيار صخري ادخلها
العنايه المركزه في غيبوبه دماغيه وثلاثه
من اخوتها ايضا في المشفى بعد ان تعدت
حالاتهم مرحله الخطر انهم ضحايا انهيار
صخريا باغتهم في المنزل ليلا في قريه الشن
بمنطقه الضباب غربي تعز
الساعه 6 مغرب فجاه عاصفه قويه فلت الصخره
على البيت
وانا خرجت يعني
ان الاطفال حقي
[موسيقى]
اول ما وصلوه وصلوه احنا
كانت تحت النقاط تحت التراب لمده نصف ساعه
وخرجوها
وبعدين تم نقلعهم لهنا طبعا هم من الفعل
المهمشين وحالتهم معدمه جدا وصلوا ما
يمتلكوش قيمه ابره حتى هكذا اذا يحول
هؤلاء انتشار ما تبقى تحت الانقاض حتى وان
كانت حيوانات او مواد ايوائيه وهكذا بدت
المنازل المدمره بالصخور فثرواتهم
الحيوانيه نفقت جميعها تحت الركام وبات
اكثر من 20 شخصا في الاسره يعيشون التشرد
في منازل المجاوره عقب وقوع الكارثه
[موسيقى]
هذه الاحداث والاصابات
ونتمنى من
المعنيه بالامر
الاجراءات المناسبه للحي الاولاد دون
تكرار مثل هذه
الواقعه ليست هذه المره الاولى التي
تتساقط فيها الصخور على منازل المواطنين
بل تمت واقعه مشابهه حدثت قبل اشهر في
منطقه الحصيب وسط المدينه اثارت حاله من
الرعب وسط السكان وامام تلك الحوادث
المتكرره جراء الامطار الغزيره والعواصف
تقف الجهات الحكوميه عاجزه عن تقديم اي حل
هل سعيد العربيه الى العناوين
عمده
لهجمات جويه على العاصمه فيما موسكو تؤكد
احباطها جميع محاولات التقدم الاوكرانيه
في دنيا
الناخبون في الكويت يتوجهون بعد قليل
لصناديق الاقتراع الاختياري 50 نائبا في
مجلس الامه
بعد غيابه عن جلسه الامس الامير هاري يدلي
بشهادته اليوم امام المحكمه في لندن في
سابقه تاريخيه
نهايه الى اللقاء عند المنتصف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات